[Musique]
il est pas là j'en profite aujourd'hui
bonjour nous allons parler de montage de
vidéos et de doha mais avant on va
résoudre le casse-tête de la semaine
prochaine je tourne une vidéo on voit
ton rose c'est d'être derrière la caméra
qui est ici ouais ou non ou derrière et
au montage pour mettre des images drôles
tu veut l'ouvrir avec moi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un enfant de cinq
ans oui parce que aujourd'hui loïc
monteur cadreur
en fait toutes les vidéos vous trouvez
un peu de belles sur ma chaîne c'est toi
qui les fait mais c'est moi et toutes
les blagues que vous trouvez un peu nul
c'est toi qui les fait pas tout un
défaut ils m'envoient des trucs fait
c'est malaga produit parce que tu as des
preuves physiques de ce que tu avances à
ce que tu as des rushes qui reste de sa
bien oui eh bien je crois
pourquoi on essaye de pertes alors qu'on
ne sait pas bon ben c'est un petit
casse-tête ensemble aujourd'hui oui je
trouvais ça très très cool en ce mois
d'août qu'on fasse une vidéo ensemble
avec loïc et du coup qui tient la caméra
et ben c'est we came tient la caméra
mon dieu mais c'est en fait d'un train
percuté que potentiellement je n'aurais
jamais besoin de toi en fait pour les
tournages
non parce que non là c'est placé par un
système de soufflerie tient mais sinon
ça alors aujourd'hui en ce sens
l'ouverture de loro file file five parce
que c'est une série d' y en a plusieurs
de un je ne sais pas combien je crois
que c'est 5,6 peut-être le dernier est
le but du jeu la seule indication que
j'ai sur le papier qui est fourni avec
c'est qu'il faut libérer la pièce de 20
centimes alors là on voit jack est une
pièce de 20 centimes on n'est fait mais
le but du jeu c'est de libérer la pièce
de 20 centimes
voilà écoute on peut attaquer comme tu
veux c'est un niveau très difficile
comme l'indiquent ce petit sifflement de
loïc comme d'habitude je vous ferai des
gros plans si on arrive à l'ouvrir et
tous assurent sur mon instagram que vous
pouvez trouver ici n'hésitez pas à
rajouter je vous y attends nous sommes
actuellement 30 1143 seront installera
mais peut-être 144,6 goudé qui bat si je
te l'assuré la phase d'exploration si tu
veux ok alors savoir comment sont ou par
non mais voilà alors et ont vu
quelques-unes de taizé vidéo
j'ai des petites idées pouvoir comment
j'ai assez rassuré comme on se masse
elle me dit qu'il a vu des vidéos comme
on peut le constater il ya une pièce il
ya une pièce centrale
voilà si elle bouge ou pas je crois
qu'elle ne bouge pas tu sais que les
petits et non les pièces rouges en euros
sont les seules pièces et nantes abl
elles sont aimants table le 1 le 2 et le
5 scènes sont des pièces et mentale donc
tu es en train de me dire il mentait
rhin
la méthode parce que quand je parle
aussi ça ne m'est pas l'agrément table
je disais du coup peut-être qu'à un
aimant peut-être qu'il ya un an je dis
pas qu'un agent tient là tu me dis ça
mais tout est en création et mortagne un
message fort et bien au premier abord là
un truc qui me semblent saute aux yeux
quand ça plaît plus que ce qui est sûr
c'est que ça saute aux yeux c'est que tu
as une pièce comme ça ouais et la têt
dessins de petites petites vis enfin oui
davis et on pourrait se dire comme ça
que ben voilà on peut si on arrive à
enlever cette pièce tu vois on peut
dévisser lévis c'est pas con parce qu'il
ya des petits exercices et moi moi je
suis je suis
mon oeil est attiré par sa où je me
demande vraiment si c'est un défaut
aussi ça fait vraiment partie du délire
tu vois ce petit trou là lui alors quoi
je pense pas qu'il se mette quelque
chose dedans dans ce qu'on a
dans ce casse tête mais je me dis
toujours il n'ya jamais rien en trop
sauf si c'est un défaut de fabrication
on essaie super spécifique du coup mais
c'est très spécifique commun mais du
coup aussi on peut noter qu'il ya des
petits désavantagerait sincères si cela
alors importe comment je suis non
j'arrive pas à voir le bout non j'ai
regardé à l'intérieur
ouais c'est que j'ai une position assez
incroyable non mais en bougeant je
voulais voir si c'était très profond par
le clan smith est très profond d'accord
autre côté dans a priori c'est une
première piste
on se dirige comme ça et donc de l'autre
côté on a beau temps clairement le nom
du casse-tête qui parfois est un indice
sur les castes est difficile ça peut
aller quand on est deux à lever les
doigts c'est que c'est une info
importante et ça des fois en fait ça
peut s'enlever en fait depuis que j'ai
fait la pandora box j'ai toujours envie
d'enlever sa avec des trucs est monté et
il n'y a vraiment pas grand chose à voir
d'autres coins ben ouais non tu vois que
la sur les côtés de ce genre des petites
réunions aussi comme si ça pouvait se
soulever comme ça tac tac tac mais c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait en fait mais
un traitement il ya un vrai petit je
regarde sud pas grand chose mais du coup
je me demande si y'a pas 15 celle des
axes qui tiens tu vois il n'y a pas de
trucs à enlever et québec les gens y en
ait un peu d'eux fake et qui n'en reste
qu'un et qu'après on ouvre ça comme ça
tu vois ce que les saf un genre inferno
pivoter essais on sent on sent une
retenue entre ces deux là mais là et
c'est de là à oui oui oui il y
effectivement ça
mais donc l'idée c'est de savoir
pourquoi ça bloque et où ça bloque
afin de débloquer sa place si la théorie
ben parce que moins de ce que j'ai
compris dans les questions faut pas
forcer pas forcément force est pas trop
où faut pas forcément forcez pas
forcément forcé j'en ai de très rares où
il fallait forcer et on a dit que chris
french et qui fait de ces excellents de
vidéos de tester il était tombé sur un
ou le résultat final ces étapes
après il ya ça c'est petit rainures où
je me dis aussi je te dis comme ça me
vient c'est simple on vivait alors à
deux pas de mauvaise idée c'est comme
quand tu es en cours avec prof dit alors
ceux qui ont une idée lever la main il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de réponse
idiote et u9 la main tu dis un truc qui
te fasse perdre et il fait bon ça c'est
qu'on prend comme je croyais qu'elle ait
pas de réponse il se bat jamais fait ça
et après tu non mais après tu t'en vas
tu piques l'école dans un cirque après
frais que tu deviens monde a une petite
idée
le mentaliste bref je vais dire si cette
pièce la bâtisse d'un centime donc toi
tig et on peut la mettre là par ce qui
semble être un mais moi je me dis
peut-être on peut la mettre là aussi
peut-être qu'un truc disais pour pour
forcer de l'intérieur tout en appuyant
sur la pièce qui dans le fond tu vois ce
que le dire est tournée peut-être je
sais pas je remercie mes salaires c'est
elles se trouvent en appuyant d'ici là
dans le fond de la pièce la claque avec
la pièce rouge peut-être ça débloque
quelque chose une faute et il faut
essayer de libérer ces faits cela ok
libérons la pièce le verrez c'est un mot
qui me disent ils ce rêve une élève
bouger c'est vrai c'est parce que j'ai
pas vu fait c'est bien fait ces gens là
et ben oui bah moi je suis toujours
je pense que j'ai fait mon taf c'est à
dire donner des théories si je pense
qu'il serait temps de passer à gagner ou
pas est un sentiment un self je pense
qu'il serait bon de passer à la pratique
alors je te propose que toi tu commences
ouais comme ça moi tu vois j'ai
l'impression des choses comme ça et je
sens si tu vas dans la bonne la bonne
direction en bonne voie un peu
ouais voie ferrée [ __ ] albi
comme ça du coup c'est un peu de la
fiche mais au moins on sera six à ce
davis ou pas est clairement comment ça
pas l'air de trop
aa à a je ne dis pas que je vais le
délit c'est parce que du coup parce que
ce serait de la triche mais c'était pas
dans la boîte mais si vous alors nous en
fait y avait pas ça on ouvre à la fois
que je fais ça c'est sûr ça déjà ça c
est pas ça mais du coup je dis ok il
dévisse donc peut-être que ta théorie
elle était bonne dans la pièce pour pour
la mettre la question là c'est comment
parce qu'elle avait quand même bien y
accoler la pièce est ce que tu le trouve
beau mais je trouve ces trucs d'accord
on part là dessus d'eybens oui je trouve
bien et je trouve très jolie et en plus
j'ai senti ces remblais ça sent bon
j'aime mais en fait ça ça suppose que du
matériel artisanale qui est fait en bois
précieux en fait c'est pour ça que je
suis vraiment amoureux de ces castes est
là celui ci je vous mets dans la
description si vous voulez le voir bien
sûr parce que si genre on fait comment
ça pourrait peut-être est-ce que je suis
en même temps non mais ça saute c'est un
truc si tu fais c'est une combinaison
magique ces gens tués
ce serait un gâchis parce que c'est 0,5
ce serait ça vingt dix pas trop de sucre
pour moi non mais ça aurait pu être sa
classe répond là il ya vraiment le jeu
en fait on le sent on le voit on le
il y en avait qu'un seul qui se
dévissent eh ouais je crois que c'était
lui voit donc en fait non c'est parce
que si on avait comme si on avait deux
on aurait pu se dire que c'est ça ah oui
c'est vrai ça qu'on voit ça je crois que
ça fait partie tu céder des éléments de
boîtes qui sont la porte vers galéré et
qui sert à rien tu sais tu penses ouais
tiens
autant je t'ai trouvé un peu prompts à
faire autant maintenant j'ai envie de le
faire on le fait c'est un 10 pouces et
le bruit comme ça de l'argent c'est la
tournée s'est en même temps si on le
regarde pas
ça va bouger
[Musique]
parce que c'est toujours pareil mais
casse tête il faut tard le défaire mais
après faudrait savoir le refaire mais
ces journées truc parce qu'elle est
casté toutes les dix jours tac 13 coups
12 coups milk ou fait pas on sait pas on
sait pas enfin lundi 5 millions de bahts
genre c'est simple non c'est peut-être
ça mais moi je propose des trucs c'est
peut-être 50
oui dit comme ça non mais pendant ce
temps là vous pouvez lier la vidéo à
tous de vous dire
bon ben c'est pas ça 50
moi j'ai bien envie de laisser que c'est
pas genre un truc me retiens cette
regarde ça s'écarte un tout petit peu là
entre les eaux
tu as vu où t'as pas vu oui j'ai vu un
truc là effectivement j'ai je ne sais
pas sur quoi j'ai appuyé en fait mais à
l'est par contre rené pous quoi je suis
contre acta nord en fait donc on vous
tue force à je force comme importe
et ça se remet direct et ça se remet
dire je pense y avait qu à mon goût
les aimants un coude et heymans à se
coller bien ça c'est un croix rouge un
mec comme ça si c'est ouvert le jeu
c'est ce côté là moi qui s'est ouvert
forcément j'ai l'impression qu'il fait
semblant de force et d'adressé
alors est-ce que c'est cassé mais je
suis ouvert rien d'ici mais pourquoi ça
c'est ça c'est que ça s'est transformé
en bois c'est la pièce de un centime ça
c'est des trois vraies vis de ça du coup
et ça c'est trois fosses vis mon gars
web
ben s'assure petit trou exactement comme
je l'avais dit ça ne sert à rien ce ça
n'avait pas du tout attiré mon attention
la pièce aller fait clairement pour no
ken sas et des deux est assez il ya que
deux éléments qui retient en fait c'est
juste ça c'est énorme mais tu vois qu'il
y avait quand même cette histoire de y
avait un seul truc non parce que ça ça
va dans le prénom mais j'avais envie de
dire un truc genre tu vois je t'avais
dit qu'il était en même temps moi je
trouve sa raison et donc là il y avait
la pièce de danse et ça ressort ben saad
est derrière mais pour quoi faire
mais j'ai pas mal de roms ont fait le
centre va du coup je me le remettre ça
que dans un calcaire toujours d'y amener
de la ssr indiquent avoir achevé
ça fait un peu que c'est comme les gens
les jeux pour enfants que tu allais
forme hexagonale du couchant
non j'déconne j'ai quand même réussi a
pas réussi à l'apex un peu sa vie c'est
inhumain c'est en grand bassin
ça change quoi la vie c'est juste c'est
pour laquelle soit plus proche peut-être
qu'on sera en tout cas pas trop d'
espaces de danse je ne sais pas possible
oui ça peut être juste glissé derrière
d'otages
j'ai forcé comme la wii board abbas
était plus facile moi c'est à temps mais
qu est-ce que c'est marrant ça ça doit
être le petit truc de bois ça m'a un peu
humilié ses côtés pas l'humiliation
l'entente était comme ça tout à fait par
le haut ah oui un bénin mais clairement
sens faite par le haut c'est extrêmement
simple mais c'est pas sûr le monsieur où
il y en a pas
ah bah oui parce que comme les aimants
sont en bas d'accord moi j'ai dû forcer
avec j'en avais le goût qui vont au
problème je te faudrait regarder leur '
un ralenti d'un siège c'est la tête
en fait je crois que j'avais pris sur
les côtés j'ai c'est de virer comme ça
bonjour tu savais ta juste non je crois
que nous avons logique
je crois que c'était un bon travail
d'équipé bravo à toi on serre la main
donc comme dans les anciens films comme
ça si tu sais c'est une affaire
rondement mené c'est eh oui la répartie
c'est important écoute il est très très
cool tu oses tu es là ok d'accord mais
c'est peut-être fait pour ça en fait
regarde c'est peut-être histoire de tusi
tu vraiment des chaussées par ces géants
des chèques a vraiment besoin de 20 100
tu les prends epsilon bas il faut sortir
le petit bout de bois quoi ces blocs de
suite ça donne un peu moins envie
connais ma valeur tilly faux car elle va
mettre le pied à l'étrier sata mal-être
salles des films comme en mai que cette
pièce à l'intérieur tenus c'est pas
possible et huawei en fait c'est pas
possible alors n'est pas possible et ce
que c'est infime et bim bim bim du coup
à l'effigié de l'hérault données facile
et nicky merci à toi merci à vous si ça
vous a plu cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
liker merci pour tous ces beaux montages
que tu fais sur la chaîne compris ça a
été un plaisir plaisir
si vous êtes abonné à machete secondaire
c'est à dire sur des machines c'est pas
une blague vous allez là vient dans la
vidéo vous avez pour cette vidéo est là
en avance et puis et puis voilà
en vrac car n'oubliez pas le nouveau
livre est sorti apparemment ça vous
plaît les retours sont bons c'est cool
liens de la description il ya le
spectacle à l'olympia en tournée bientôt
voilà très bientôt ciao